[Música]
a
hola qué tal buenas tardes buenos días
bueno pues nada yo os vengo a hoy a
hablar de amor qué bonito es verdad que
chulo si les vengo a hablar de amor y
seguro y cuando digo la palabra amor lo
primero que se os ocurre es pensar en
familia marido novio hijos verdad
mascota a veces pero a alguien se le
ocurre pensar o asociar la palabra amor
y por ejemplo jefe
no a amor y profesores
clientes es curioso
es una cosa que no hacemos sin embargo
cuando leemos la definición de amor que
la tengo aquí apuntada porque no me las
tengo que buscar hoy la definición
exacta es el sentimiento de vivo afecto
hacia una persona o cosa el teléfono
a la que se le desea todo lo mejor
hombre pues basándonos en esta
definición no sé qué deciros pero si la
situación laboral y estudiantil es
normal y no estamos hablando de ningún
ninguna situación grave pues yo a mi
jefe le deseo todo lo mejor porque
quiero que me siga contratando verdad a
mis clientes les deseo todo lo mejor
porque quiero que sigan comprando me a
mis profesores también les deseo todo lo
mejor verdad porque quiero que sigan por
lo menos escuchándome enseñándome si es
posible y poniéndome buenas notas pero
es curioso porque no tenemos en cuenta y
fijaros qué
desgraciadamente iba a decir pero no en
la vida nos pasamos más tiempo con estas
personas que con las personas que
realmente queremos fijarnos en esto
todos nacemos más o menos a los 0
alguien ha nacido antes por saberlo
después no pero hasta aquí bien hasta
aquí hechos reales si todo va bien y si
nos va bien podemos aguantar más o menos
hasta aquí podemos morirnos antes
también vale no lo digo para que lo
sepáis por si acaso no sabíais vale y
con un poco de suerte y si la salud
acompaña incluso un poquito más aquí
empezamos a pues trabajar o estudiar
como más en serio sí y hasta aquí
trabajamos los que tenéis suerte porque
eso los autónomos
no dejamos nunca bueno mensaje de hoy no
os hagáis autónomos en fin
no no no andrea que era amor el amor es
verdad es verdad segundo entonces que
pasa de 0 a 18 más o menos somos
contentos estamos felices ay qué bien
mira que bien no tengo demasiadas
responsabilidades todo va bien a partir
del 67 los que os juviles es como que
descanso ya está bueno algunos se
jubilan y se mueren también
verdad hombre espera te un segundito
vale qué es lo que pasa entre los 18 y
los 67 atención de atención toma ya
todo el rato muchas horas al día
entonces qué pasa aquí donde tenemos que
poner el amor en la decisión que tomamos
qué decisión tomamos con el trabajo
tomamos esta decisión me lo voy a tomar
así o tomó esta decisión me enamoro y me
re enamoro de mi trabajo de mis
compañeros de mi jefe de mis profesores
y no es fácil os aseguro que no es fácil
porque porque al principio yo sé y vamos
a hacer un remember when the inglés
acordémonos todos el primer día de
trabajo el primer día que llegamos a la
universidad así como llegábamos
ilusionados
nerviosos a la expectativa verdad y
ahora cómo vamos
nerviosos a expectativas más o menos
pasa lo mismo con la primera cita o sea
estamos haciendo siempre paralelismo
entre la vida laboral y la vida amorosa
en la primera cita como vas nervioso
ducha ojos pero
a la expectativa no depilado si podemos
pillar la primera noche para que esperar
si
después de 20 años de matrimonio el
invierno es muy largo
entonces claro el problema no es que
falta amor el problema es que dejamos de
cuidar los pequeños detalles y dejamos
de mirar y ser conscientes de aquellas
pequeñas cosas que nosotros podemos
hacer las que somos responsables para
que ese amor dure dure dure y dure damos
por hecho las cosas y poco a poco que va
haciendo nos vamos des enamorando y pasa
una cosa muy curiosa cuando nos des
enamoramos que lo primero que solemos
hacer es acusar al otro si hacemos es
que ya no me quieres es que ya no me
miras ya a nivel laboral también es que
no me hacen caso que el cliente no me
compra es que el profesor me tiene manía
verdad vale pues vamos a hacer una cosa
interesante vais a acusarme a mí venga
todos esos dedos arriba acusación venga
venga venga no os veo pero me imagino
que estáis todos con el dedo arriba
os puedo sentir puedo sentir si vale
pues este dedo está acusando verdad y
estos tres a quién acusan
será que tengo alguna responsabilidad en
el que dure el amor en que la chispa
siga así claro que sí que es lo que ha
dejado de hacer qué es lo que podría
volver a hacer y qué es lo que voy a
hacer otra vez para re enamorarme de las
personas a mi alrededor
entonces si os parece bien vamos a hacer
un paralelismo entre lo que es una
relación amorosa no el proceso de la
relación amorosa
lo que podemos hacer a nivel laboral o
estudiantil y que es lo primero que pasa
cuando nos enamoramos de alguien
el flechazo ves a alguien y haces ojo o
jr
me gustas sí y es curioso porque no
tiene que ver con el físico no tiene que
ver con si eres guapo o feo vale pero es
cierto que te enamoras de lo de fuera
quien me diga que no yo me enamoro del
interior es como el xerez
puede ser que luego sí pero de entrada
te atrae el físico estamos de acuerdo
porque además lo que decía la belleza no
tiene nada que ver porque cuando tú
estás como jaime enamorada de un chico
una chica y le enseñas la foto a tus
amigos todo mundo dice bueno pues
tampoco para tanto
y tú que lo ves tan bello y tan guapo yo
pero no entiendo por qué
pues es lo que pasa el flechazo entonces
que podemos hacer para que ese flechazo
dure lo primero y lo más importante es
mirarse al espejo es mirarse al espejo y
aceptar lo que vemos una persona que no
se quiere difícilmente va a conseguir
que los demás la quieran así que la
primera frase del día es acepta lo que
ves quiere lo que eres y es sé que es
difícil es sé que es difícil porque
normalmente cuando nos miramos en espejo
lo primero que hacemos es ver aquello
que no nos gusta pero es una cuestión de
cambio de perspectiva es decir hoy voy a
dejar de mirar lo que no me gusta voy a
empezar a mirar lo que es y porque
seguro que hay algo y para eso tengo un
truco infalible vamos a cambiar
de onomatopeya cuando nos miramos al
espejo normalmente cuando nos miramos al
espejo la gran mayoría de tampoco quiero
generalizar demasiado hacemos hace
bollywood
voz pues vamos a cambiar el bus por él
todos juntos conmigo 123 haber sabido
hacerlo 1 2 y 3
exacto entonces
tenéis muy fáciles entonces nos mira
muchas veces bush vamos a hacer
si en todos los espejos escaparates por
la calle
os parecerá una chorrada pero a cabo de
momento te lo vas cayendo mírame
estoy divina padre hay una frase que
para eso me encanta que es fake it if
you may que tú ves haciendo lo que algún
día te lo creerás te lo juro hijo por
edad porque en un momento dado dices uy
me queda poco tiempo o me creo que estoy
buena
no vamos lejos así que acepta lo que ves
quiere lo que eres y el segundo truco
que es maravilloso para el flechazo es
una cosa que es facilísimo de hacer que
es dar sonrisa
los niños sonríen unas 400 veces al día
los adolescentes ya baja a 14
bueno riise que los adultos sonreímos 4
es muy triste nuestra vida
pero porque yo creo que la sonrisa lo
que pensamos siempre es yo solo sonrío
cuando me pasa algo bonito no tú sonríe
antes porque a lo mejor por la sonrisa
te pasará algo bonito
hay un escritor que escribió el poder
oculto de la sonrisa que se llama ron es
lindo más corta del aspecto
whitman pacman me da igual no buscarlo
he creado he puesto la semilla de vamos
a buscar quién es vale entonces este
señor dice que la sonrisa tiene varios
efectos el primero es el pegamento
social es mucho más fácil acercarse
enamorarse de alguien que está así que
alguien que está así
estamos de acuerdo entonces no cuesta
nada lo segundo es que además crea
emociones si tú ves sonriendo por la
calle vas a crear o sabes cómo las
neuronas de espejos y yo voy a si la
gente cree pasa estas aves
y de una manera imprevista dirá ah pues
mira yo también sabes
y entonces tenemos todo así
que no cuesta nada os lo juro es otra
vez como falsearlo pero al final será
verdad es esto es musculares pómulo
arriba
vamos a probarlo 3 y pópulo arriba
y basta un día así que tal que tal hoy
fatal
cómo te ha ido lecciones de entradas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
qué tal el examen horroroso
pero ves que el mensaje más suave no
funciona bueno voy rápido que esté
enrollando vale flechazo lo tenemos para
después una vez que tenemos el flechazo
pasa el segunda parte la segunda parte
del proceso de enamoramiento que es la
seducción
una vez que me gustas voy a poner en
marcha toda la mecánica física para
gustarte y eso tiene que ver con el
cuerpo el cuerpo y su uso influyen en la
conducta voy a pasar rápido por aquí
acordaros que hay que tener una buena
postura corporal porque es mucho más
fácil ligar así que llegará así y y
además que te tomen más en serio pero
además de esto hay dos temas esenciales
dentro de la expresión que son para mí
básicas que es mirar a los ojos sí que
es aunque últimamente hacemos poco nos
hablan y sí sí sí dime si es ese jajaja
no vale entonces si no miramos a los
ojos captamos la información
evidentemente que sí pero no captamos la
emoción y a veces en el mensaje es mucho
más importante la emoción el cómo te lo
han dicho para enamorarte
qué te han dicho para que me entendáis
vosotros que sois tan jóvenes enviar y
hablar con alguien sin mirar a los ojos
es como enviar un whatsapp sin emoticono
el mensaje no es el mismo cuántas
parejas se han peleado aquello que damos
por qué es así lo digo normal con que os
diga
quedamos muy distinto hoy mira otra vez
la sonrisa
y luego hay un tema que me parece
esencial para la colaboración como decía
pablo no hay que colaborar tenemos que
hacer cosas juntos y para ello tenemos
que ser muy generosos muy generosos con
el ritmo ajeno entonces vamos a tener
que captar lo que yo llamo empatía
rítmica la empatía rítmica es muy
complicada y tenemos que ser muy
generosos y realmente tenemos muchas
ganas de enamorar al otro os recuerdo
que si yo quiero que el otro me entienda
la responsabilidad de la comunicación es
mía no del interlocutor os pongo pequeño
ejemplo imaginaros que yo necesito ahora
que me manchado comprarme una camiseta
blanca y tengo dos minutos antes de
entrar a dar la charla y como dentro de
la tienda
con una loca no antes de que llegue a
seguridad
es muy probable que venga algún
dependiente dependiente y me diga hola
[Música]
qué tal
en que te puede ayudar
[Música]
y yo lo maté
aquí no hay empatía ritmo y canto si yo
entro con un ritmo así la persona que me
ve dice venga por ella
iba al ataque así que si yo tengo un
equipo de personas con ritmo yo me tengo
que adaptar al ritmo más o menos esto es
fácil o difícil cuando tenemos un
compañero que es en plan hola qué tal
que era para ohl y el trabajo
y tú
aquí el gran error que cometemos todos
es intentar motivar al lento
acordaros amor actual lento de más dices
me acaba tú puedes ganar y qué hacer
entonces
y le explota la cabeza
no lo entiendes
[Aplausos]
sí
estamos hablando de amor y yo quiero a
esta persona quiero este equipo quiero
que realmente funcione así que voy a
respirar antes de hablar con mi amigo de
ritmo zen
voy a empezar qué tal cómo estás hoy
el otro bien y tú
oye sabes que el trabajo era para hoy
en serio
tuve
pero qué va a pasar que de repente tira
lo veis que no hace falta es tres aros
tanto
entonces me diréis ya pero que
conseguimos es verdad que hay que tener
un poquito más de paciencia y tardas un
poquito más pero en cuanto a tu
enganchas rítmicamente con esa persona
que piensa ver a alguien me entiende en
el equipo poco a poco es como un tren no
eres la locomotora estamos enganchados y
venga
y podemos volver a ritmo normal lo
repito esto es muy difícil pero
realmente es lo aconsejo así que hemos
hecho el flechazo
estamos en la seducción y normalmente lo
que pasa en toda relación es
de repente te enfadas y se acaba el amor
así que atención aquí cuidado con este
nada más que tú es que tú en un momento
las crisis son maravillosas enfadarse
discutir estar ahí es fantástico porque
es una oportunidad increíble para
conocer un aspecto distinto de las
personas con las que trabajamos o con
las que estudiamos pero hay que querer
resolverlas y ese es el gran problema
nuestro ego en general no nos deja
resolver la crisis porque estamos en
plan yo tengo razón en sí entonces como
estamos hablando de amor y si realmente
queremos dar amor que vamos a tener que
hacer lo primero y lo más indispensable
en cualquier crisis es pedir perdón me
desesperé si la culpa es mía no ves que
se queda igual tú no pides perdón por el
contenido tú pides perdón por la
situación tú vas aquí a pesares oye mira
no estamos de acuerdo pero disculpa y si
esa persona es mínimamente inteligente y
vale la pena que eso también es un buen
barómetro no te dirá pues te da razón
qué tontería enfadarnos por esto vamos a
intentar resolverlo así que lo primero
en una crisis para enamorarse pedir
perdón y lo segundo
ser positivo un segundo os voy a contar
la diferencia no estoy hablando de
optimismo el optimista es el que todo lo
ve bien que dice que tal ya verás tiras
súper bien es mejor no
si aquel optimista que ve siempre el
vaso medio lleno
si siempre es tan feliz decir por qué no
el optimista es este el positivo es
distinto el positivo quién es es el que
coge ese vaso que está medio lleno y
medio vacío y lo llena de una vez por
todas dice ya está bien de tanta
tontería vamos a hacer algo el positivo
es quien toma la decisión de hacer algo
para resolver de hacer algo para
enamorar el que deja de culpar a los
demás y encuentra el camino para la
solución fijaros el negativo es aquel
que busca el culpable el negativo
siempre dice quién ha sido el positivo
siempre dice cómo lo resolvemos así que
con todo esto tengo y tengo una última
pregunta para vosotros decidís nos
enamoramos o no
[Aplausos]
[Música]